[Applause]
let's get on with the starter
steph how are you doing hi big white
aiden little chris hey dude andrew
you're all right
nice to meet you i'm big chris so four
talented estate agents
we are i'm very talented amateur cooks
right
yes estate agents have the most amazing
reputation
yeah as well for being great
bullshitters
tonight there's gonna be no [ __ ]
tonight we're gonna look after us uh and
we gotta deliver
okay guys come here let's do this
together any questions as we go along
please i'd really appreciate if you
asked
yeah right what you got in here sage
onion and potatoes don't flood it with
butter
otherwise it goes soggy okay
so nice and flat that's it and push
yourself around the sides yeah
so this is called a potato rosti
basically a nice sort of
crispy potato cake yes potatoes cooked
so it doesn't take that long but be
careful you don't catch it yeah i don't
want to see it burning okay all right
eggs
make sure you don't break the yolk guys
very very quiet no questions
uh nice black pudding it's cooked
already it's already made yeah it's nice
and spicy three slices proportion
turn them over let your black pudding
rest right so fast and good yes
so first off potato cake nicely on there
yes
eggs out on black pudding over
when you mix the black pudding and the
egg yolk is delicious
yeah okay a little bit of salad just the
top of the plate
all right let's do it right now wait
wait wait wait wait
then put it vinegar that's it over would
you pay for that step
i would yeah table nine yeah let's go
guys yes
right listen up four customers table one
please yeah four black putting four
buildings go up four tier misu
yes shane let's go guys
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] me i was made for the [ __ ]
andrew
the yogurt first there is it sorry the
yolks first andrew yes it has
it's first sorry all right sorry chef
very sorry just [ __ ] change it let's
go all right
oh [ __ ] you know it keeps on breaking
[ __ ] [ __ ] egg
stupid [ __ ] egg keep the patty down
let's go
no mate chris don't worry if you guys
want me to start again
work man i'm doing another one
you've just scraped it off the stove
yeah and you put it back here would you
eat that sorry no
no no let's go quick crisp best thing to
do like i showed you a little pan like
that and just slide it off like that
there you go now put it up to the rest
[Music]
yeah
yeah this is such a simple starter each
and every one of you are capable of
doing this but right now
we're all over the shop yes right let's
take the cake on the plate andrew let's
go sorry what's your bag what about
christmas
eggs please don't put the trays on the
fingers don't burst the yolk yes
definitely salad please there's an egg
in there why are you doing dressing in
there
watch me shake shake video and mutter's
at the bottom just drizzle drizzle just
watch
roll around do a little dance yeah [ __ ]
the dance now
there we go service please no longer
waited yes
table 14. sorry about the delay okay
let's go
let's tell 14. let's get chef
this lot i'm convinced they can [ __ ]
cook never ever trust an estate agent
[Music]
being a chef being a build up you have
to work for your money
whereas i can pick up a couple of phone
calls and i've made my 6 000 pounds
there's opportunities to make a lot of
money i might made by money and success
the way i see it everyone needs bricks
and mortar everyone's out there to make
money just the red wine
don't need the red wine as a team we're
very good at cooking they've got to be
golden brown on both sides
you know with your baby sweeter and your
peppers your chickens and things like
that it's a challenge i like using my
hands
i like to be busy i think you're fine
i'm the hardest worker now
you know stop blowing your own trumpet
sir if anyone's going to wind up gordon
the most
scotty steph steph he doesn't mean to
hurt his will
i can't take orders from anyone you can
mix it and i'll do that just put it in
this it's a brigade
we're going to be the best 45 minutes
have gone get yourself on you we serve
four tables
move your ass a little
no no i couldn't eat it would you pay
for it
yeah i'd pay for that in in here yeah
not
in a calf no it's way too much you
wouldn't get food like that in a cafe
well you could get baked you got
you know a black pudding an egg what you
get it's not good like that you really
get sausages with it did you understand
the menu because i devised a little easy
format menu
something to make you feel less
intimidated pictures of the size
little explanation how did you know as
much as you choked i didn't know that
veal was a baby cow oh
no i'll get away with that and in
general you're actually quite a fussy
eater aren't you i'm not fussy
you're demanding [ __ ] no no no cheese no
fruit
no it's no no cheese yeah no onions
no tomatoes no mushrooms right now sadly
[ __ ] you now they're emotional
fussy [ __ ] what ah yeah all right you
you you
you know you eat well what's that what
they might taste
no no i i i don't eat a lot i really
don't
but and what i do eat is is not that
great for me shocker obviously that was
the main course i
enjoyed the starting you haven't paid
for it yes absolutely very happy
i don't know about the rest of these
they're very excited
personally i think that egg was well
overcooked the starter was okay but
it was something that i'd get at home my
mum would probably cook a bit better
okay results for the starters let's go
what'd you reckon
25 the number of customers are prepared
to pay for the starter
[ __ ] out 14 yeah only 14 now 50.
36 customers refuse to pay yeah why
too long obviously and the egg all rule
are overcooked
obverance unbelievable yeah so far that
is the
worst score ever
seriously yeah [ __ ] what can we do
though man let's just see what we can do
around there that's it steph you can
come back yes you know don't worry you
can come back from that sorry crap
let's make up for it and get 50 for
maine yes
next on the menu my son jack goes from
boy to action man
when you think you're in line reach
forward and pull the trigger
yeah good shot first time around
it's time for the main course a
delicious feeler scallop with caponata
and the heat is on for chris moyles yes
wow
what's the matter with you
welcome back to the f-word now it's
never too early to teach your son about
birds
[Music]
i'm taking jack off in his first ever
foodie adventure in search of something
that we've really stopped eating
a rook rook
pie is an old english classic but today
it's almost entirely forgotten
a shame because thousands of rooks are
shot every spring they've become
a real pest damaging crops and stealing
other birds eggs
you're not scared about going in the
woodlands you look like an action man
like that
we'll be shooting with gamekeeper dave
whitby an old mate of mine
who's got a problem with rooks on his
land welcome good to see you mate good
to see you
first time ever shooting a gun yes
excited yeah
do you want to go back and call mommy no
let's go buddy
pound how about you miss yes
that's enough when you think you're in
line reach forward and pull the trigger
yeah good shot first time around
good shot you got the target are you
ready for another one more
take care plane when you're ready
wait what was the peck no no that's two
pounds aren't you
oh no jack's a chip off the old block
but today it'll be me shooting the rooks
we're heading into the woods
where the birds nest the traditional way
to call rooks is to shoot the young
as they leave their nests okay buddy
load me up please
i'll give me five don't miss dad
don't miss that don't scare them
bloody hell jack there's one through
there look
oh just up through there safety catch
off yeah
you got a leaf instead damn right see if
you can spot me jack
i think i'm just seeing one black there
okay good man
good man excellent good shot thanks
buddy
see if we can spot another one see that
good job there's not much meat on a rook
so we'll need at least six to feed the
three of us
uh how exciting is this buddy
there
right good one just landed through here
mate
good shot
good excellent now can we go and get
them yeah i need one go get it on
quickly
jack may not be old enough to hunt for
real but he makes a damn good
gun dog well done jack yeah it's got
blood on its feet yeah of course it's
gonna have blood on there let's go stop
acting like a girl
you know warm witches come here huh
amazing huh quite clean shots
good man
[Music]
i've never eaten rook before so i have
no idea what it tastes like
but with a little tlc we can bring this
forgotten food
back to now we need to pull people's
plates back for me
and rip off the breasts please quick as
that isn't it
well listen mate you're doing a great
job there you know that huh that's his
liver
yeah we could eat that as well yep and
there's his heart there look
turn it upside down that's it on his
breast like now from there look watch
turn it around and then we're just going
to take the breasts off there
okay there we go see yeah not that
smaller breast is it
huh we're going to do something very
very simple just a really nice rook
salad almost like a pigeon salad with
green beans spring onions beetroot and a
hazelnut vinaigrette
so we're going to sort of lightly
marinade the rook first some salt
and pepper on there please nicely and
rub the garlic over there please jack
now a little bit of hazelnut oil and a
little bit of sherry vinegar
now get your fingers in there it smells
really nice
nice yeah good while the rook marinades
it's time for the salad
green beans beetroot spring onion and
oak leaf lettuce
good lovely drain the beans and add some
salt
hazelnut oil and coriander smells yeah
absolutely dude ready for the rock yes
yep
okay so touch of olive oil in very very
quickly
wow literally seconds put the rest of
the marinade in there as well
okay
you don't want any rock because you
don't like rock do you i do no you don't
let's go buddy
they're a lot more tender i thought they
would be no this for me is as good as if
not better than pigeon
it just looks like a bit of venison yeah
i think it's about time that something
like this
bird rook should find his way back on
traditional british menus yeah
absolutely i i'm
truly surprised how good that was you
happy with yours yeah
yeah that was delicious
now it's time for the brigade to take on
the main course god help me
[Music]
it's got a paville caponata it's
delicious it's very lean it's good for
you
and it's a great alternative to beef now
caponata basically it's like a
ratatouille but without all the tomato
puree so you can identify exactly what's
in it
chop peppers celery
onions aubergines now
it's really important to have something
like low gene inside a caponata
it gives it that sort of bittersweet
flavor
hot pan olive oil
season
[Applause]
[Music]
red wine vinegar and that sort of wakes
everything up
tomato basil
olives capers lovely
smells amazing out onto a plate
and that stops it from overcooking and
turning mush
wow go up a veil now
we're going to panic it basically that
means flour egg wash and bread crop
three very simple stages a couple of
tablespoons of flour
eggs breadcrumbs parmesan
but these will take it to a different
dimension
[Music]
a nice heavy coating of breadcrumbs and
palms and cheese prevents the veal
from drying out and now she's ready for
the pan olive oil
just just starts to smoke in she goes
i love that sound if it goes into a cold
pan with olive oil
you've got the scallop greasy we only
turn it once it can rip or tear
quite easily check the colour
wow now this is where it gets really
exciting
pine nuts capers butter
and that helps to toast the pine nuts
fry off the capers
and really give the most amazing flavour
lovely basil just the heat
out of the butter will start to cook the
basil
capanata be generous with it
wow and then with the veal
up and on
summer's here vela scallop with
caffenata
done right pasta
it's a very fine spaghetti it's already
cooked so just reheating it
yes in literally 30 seconds onto the hot
plate let's go
okay parsley running through there top
of the plate
fresh pasta on
the vehicle goes on if you make 50
portions like that
we've got to do it man you will have the
biggest comeback ever okay
right wait wait wait wait wait and then
just go
come on boys
let's go chris yes yeah four veal away
let's go
hey chris we're not [ __ ] this up all
right come on come on come on
you have to seize it first yeah season
of it so chef do you have to season the
ville that's right yeah
don't put a bunch until we wait for the
first side cooks
wait wait just wait just relax
can we [ __ ] watch the pants please
they're all on fire now yes
guys oh they're [ __ ] i mean this is a
joke
there's an insult to catering please
where there's nothing where'd you put it
i haven't touched it i'm just dealing
with the wheel
where's my place we clean the place then
guys at least show that you care a
little [ __ ] bit yeah
sell this please i told you number eight
yes let's go
down go
steph yeah
clear down guys
the veal is quite soggy so it's not got
that kind of nice light crispiness
around it it's quite
wet and a bit sort of stodgy on the
plate i like the capers and the olives
with the veal it was really nice yeah
i definitely have it again i'm not
particularly enjoying it it's
the the feel is woefully soggy it's like
a piece of
like wet brillo pad results yes main
course let's go quickly right step how
do you think you did i don't think we
did that badly
25 and that's not bad for you well after
the 14
i don't think 25 or 30 is bad let's see
okay out of 50. how many customers paid
for the main course
21 what decided to pay
[ __ ] me that's not bad that's [ __ ]
right here we go again enjoy the main
course yeah
lovely yes yeah i'm surprised you
[ __ ] got it they are an
absolute nightmare in there state asians
all right
yes i i thought they had a look of
tossers about them i liked it but um i i
wasn't sure what everything was
right the guppinata
italian version of like a ratatouille
but without the heavy tomatoes
one while i was like in charlie brown i
just i on here
i've eaten it so i've not been rude okay
okay okay now you clean love your food
who comes at home
yeah no [ __ ] how often do you have
takeaways come up a couple of times a
week
i wouldn't say four four yeah
four times a week i got a christmas
a surprise for you yes i'm going to
phone them
please don't upset me i won't upset them
right
hi it's called ramsay i'm calling on
behalf one of your regular customers mr
chris moyles do you know him yes i do
he's a regular customer of us
what does he normally take away what is
it i think it's the chicken curry with
no onion
the chicken curry with no onion is that
right yeah
yeah and my move right now i'd like to
place
the exact same order delivered to the
f-word restaurant listen
i'll give you a 20 pound tip if you get
here within 20 minutes okay we'll
see you shortly okay thank you
right this is a challenge no i'm serious
i want to show you
before he gets here yeah that we will
cook together yeah
when now something fresh right delicious
fast food
curry okay let's go right ginger
chillies garlic lemongrass right all
into there just pour it all in pour it
all in
okay yes lemongrass so we're gonna make
it like a curry paste okay
a bit of oil right shake shake shake
that's it good
okay good good right into the pan
yeah good nice oh no no the thing fell
off not the [ __ ] blade
but you didn't tell me chicken in right
i'm doing exactly the same you know that
okay
exactly the same lime leaves in soy
sauce in
all the way around how much about a
hundred mil okay we've got to move our
ass now otherwise [ __ ]
we will get here soon trust me just nice
he'll never be here in 20 minutes
what's that seriously come what is that
fish
come on really no no i don't know what
is it come on i don't know
it's a cinnamon stick right okay what
cinnamon is okay
chicken said off yes wow
[Music]
okay right smell that what does it smell
cream oh [ __ ] off come on
there's coconut milk
aren't you happy with that well um yeah
what do you do with these
right they're green beans yes
right that just gives it a little bit of
sort of body yeah i'm
don't cut your fingers off right now
okay what do i do with it look yeah
that's it and then throw it in i'm going
to chop it now okay hand on all right do
not cut your fingers please
and in look i'm watching yeah just all
in there nicely
okay okay okay good
i've never made that okay forever fast
you can come on
no no come on come on come on i have him
coming up coming
oh fire right that's it quick no bring
the apron on come on i'm gonna bring the
food
part of the challenge bring the plate
man so
you forgot tell me to bring it that's
the challenge but the plate is there
it's your food oh [ __ ]
oh god let's go
okay okay
dude oh dear oh dear well done yeah now
huh
[Applause]
nice to see you let's see what's in
there chicken curry no
onions you should also get a free papa
job is it free papa dom in there there
is yeah
okay we're going for the tags now side
by side yes okay okay
i i just cook right all right so
you have a taste and you as well i cook
this by the way
how's that i don't know i'm gonna wait
for god's reaction before i use it
that is nice really seriously
i think you did you know what that's
nice do you like that seriously yeah
right
please don't get me banned no but oh too
big
it's nice but very greasy but mr moore's
loved it anyway doesn't he i have to say
i actually prefer the one you make
thank you no no seriously and let's be
honest a lot easier a lot quicker
and just think good food can be made
faster
and better than a takeaway yes
you you did i know yes yeah okay thank
you thank you
thanks for coming no problem good to see
you guys thank you very much
next on the menu builders put their junk
food ways behind them
um i'm going to show you my tool now
yeah
it's time for dessert an italian classic
tiramisu
and comedienne miracule is hot stuff in
the recipe challenge well it's quite
instantaneous actually
sexy grandma
welcome back to the f word here's the
first builders doing things quickly
we all think that builders are lazy are
slackers who are always on a tea break
so when i heard there were three
builders from essex that were constantly
whinging the fact that they
never had chance to eat properly or cook
for themselves i had to meet them
these boys rip out and replace kitchens
across essex and they reckon
this leaves them no time to cook or eat
properly
[Music]
i'm fed up eating the same thing every
day it's just pork pies
chocolate bars crisps you just really
don't get the time to go out there and
get something to eat
on a proper basis it's always the case
nearest location where you're working
that's where you're going to go and eat
we'd love golden to help us create
something
ideally within half an hour to keep us
on fire throughout the day
everyone's got time to cook if they've
got the right recipes and i mean
everyone essex builders
now they're probably having a [ __ ]
bacon sandwich all set on their ass
gentlemen good morning how are we tired
tony good to see you boy you're welcome
i'm harry harry nice to see you oh my
gary
gary how are you everybody good bye mate
yeah so why have you got a reputation
being such lazy [ __ ]
uh not us definitely on this side no way
we're dealing with people's homes this
is not some
you know building site where uh if you
are sitting on your ass in the port
cabin or something
you can get away with it right how long
would it really seriously take to
to rip the kitchen out without any tea
breaks or bacon butter yeah
about an hour maximum i'd like to see
how difficult it is ripping out a
kitchen
i'd like to become a proper builder yeah
i like to become a proper chef
maybe not with [ __ ] bling bling like
that
[Music]
can you get my hammer four out of that
box first place mate hammer four yeah
[ __ ] man what is the hammer for the
banging
[Music]
what tattoo have you got there what is
it the tattoo pg tips
you work your ass off yet you're [ __ ]
abusing yourselves
i'm going to show you my tool now my
tool is a powerful gas stove in the
builder's tent
there's still half an hour demolishing
left to do so i'm going to show the
rubble brothers
that they can cook a delicious lunch in
less than 25 minutes
yeah we haven't got much time yeah we're
gonna do a very quick easy
beast chew
[Music]
onions garlic thyme hey look at the
style of this
see that the secret behind this dish is
one part so it's like a one pot wonder
yeah
yeah okay simple philosophy no color no
flavor
the reason why i've cut them into small
chunks like that
is to cook it faster these guys have
better get a move on i am not going to
be beaten by a builder with a bum crap
big enough to park a bike in
[Music]
no smell
tablespoon of tomato puree
so creme fraiche it just lines up a
little bit
that is that is my special type amazing
how quick it comes together
gary this is where all the hard work's
been going on
derek you've been working hard my money
together
you'd never get this squally food from a
takeaway no all right i can't believe
you cooked this mate
yeah i'm going back to my own kitchen
now but first
here this
is for you guys yeah i want it in the
back of the van i want you to use it
turn it on get it hot put your pan on
and cook
yes definitely i've always wanted a drum
[Laughter]
machine
pancake timber soup stick to your pears
work together let's go
start whisking ice and sugar in pour in
start with
it into an hour yes yes let's go yes
enough vanilla masala
yep yeah good right cream in let's go
you continue with skin cream in let's go
steph taste it yes
little crisp put in the background to
set please yeah let's go time for
dessert
an italian classic
[Music]
tiramisu basically pick me up that's
what it means in italian
but it's easy simple delicious and very
very fast
we split it into two bowls mascarpone
put that into the bowl and just let it
go nice and soft
in the next bowl 150ml of cream
icing sugar whisk
now it's really important that we don't
over whip this cream we're just looking
like a nice
sort of thick lava consistency
no more than that
already within seconds it's got nice and
sort of light and soft
vanilla extract now we use an extract
over fresh mirror
because it gives a really nice sort of
dense dark color
masala wine it's got a really nice sort
of cafe lay color now
on the cream coffee now it's really
important
that coffee is ice cold just add in
thirds don't add it all shred away
[Applause]
fold in our cream and icing sugar
[Music]
lovely so it's a really nice
light turmeric that is fast
and sets within 20 minutes in the fridge
bowl
coffee ladies fingers and just
into the coffee turn them round and out
again so what happens now they're soggy
on the outside
still nice and crispy in the center
take your martini glass fingers in
pretty generous with it
fridge 20 minutes
chocolate great and look
nice little shards and then finally
cocoa powder
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful italian tomato with ladies
fingers
done
i'm going to dip and get this ready for
you come on bro presentation man
four away big chris let's go four away
[Music]
be careful not too long see they're
coming out really soggy you want to come
back to really hard
to put it in the most important thing
about this challenge is get it out fast
now yes
why they're coming out so
please
there's four
they should be flying out there's
actually nothing cooked guys you're just
putting it together
now just put it in a glass that's
actually that's the one with glasses
customer glasses go please double 14.
let's go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
dessert was absolutely gorgeous really
light and fluffy
and i love the the moist biscuit it was
it was really really stunning i really
really loved it
what i've got so many mouths
now goodness gracious me miracial is
going to try and beat me in the recipe
challenge
ready as i'll ever be now you're
cooking something authentic yeah yes i'm
cooking
my um my turkey dal takada yeah which
is a kind of staple punjabi dish yeah
very much thank you very simple
so the idea is that you stake the dish
and i have to come up with my own
version of it so i'm going to do
a vegetable korma and someone will use
lentils um squash aubergine carrot and
you're gonna have what in yours
basically tomatoes lentils and spices
it's very basic
fantastic i cannot believe i'm cooking
vegetarians you know what i'm saying
to meat man isn't it my god now why did
you choose this particular dish
i cook it a lot it's it's a real
favorite with the family and of course
lentils are really really good for you
does it make you fart uh yeah really
badly well not me i'm a lazy i don't do
that yeah why is that
ladies don't fart we don't fart it's
never
never we blow our noses very loudly and
we will spell the air that way
my wife farts no don't say that and
and then she blames the children which
is so unfair yeah children are very
useful for that
and dogs fantastic i'm so glad we're
talking about bottom things i'll be
cooking this is lovely i know
i know now my god
your ring's enormous mr nancy
mira goodness gracious me my ring's
enormous thank you for that my darling
right i'm not used to talking on such a
big thing what are you doing there
i'm basically frying up the ginger
garlic cumin seeds and mustard seeds
which are going to form the basis of the
dal you have to really make sure that
cumin seeds are cooked they need at
least two minutes because if you
undercook them they make
quite a bitter taste in the dal so
you're going to be quite careful with
them
now in here garlic ginger shallots i'm
just going to make a very quick
sort of paste and blend them that helps
to thicken the corner
and give it some sweetness what those
spices you put in there my daddy
um i'm putting in garam masala nice
ground coriander lovely now i'm using
garam masala as well
it's the all-purpose spice oh yes what
lentils are you using there
i'm using a mixture of red lentils and
split mung
i find that mung on its own is very
watery
yeah and if you mix them the red lentils
are a bit firmer so you get a nicer
consistency
so onions mustard seeds star and nice
and cinnamon stick now that's just to
infuse the oil
just to get everything going in a way
that we're sort of getting it nice and
spicy and making the foundation and i'm
going to pop in
a whole green chili oh whole a rather
large bunch
that is a very large one yeah yes have
you ever been in an indian kitchen and
actually you know cooked
i live in a blue linden kitchen what do
i need to go to one in a restaurant no
no but in terms
that's what i do get paid for if you do
in a restaurant but i've spent a
childhood
my whole childhood watching my mum and
my aunties cook really oh yeah
from when i was really little is that
how the inspiration for the q mars is
that how it sort of arrived
yeah from the family point of view
absolutely because that is hysterical i
grew up surrounded by
very strong funny women you know
completely away from the cliche of what
people think indian women are about
and food was a huge part of my childhood
food is a huge part of indian culture
it's how we connect and it's
i think for my parents as well it's how
they keep home alive when we were little
it was like soul food indian food was
like the living connection to that
home you know that's what food should be
about food's about love isn't it family
who did love
in fact i couldn't love anyone that
didn't love food yep
really no i don't like hot
food no i know that seems blasphemous
for an indian but actually i think a lot
of
what people mistake for curry yeah it's
just a whole lot of chili and not much
else and i think good indian cooking has
layers of flavour in it
is that because you get ring steamed
yeah i do actually
see it's it's quite common in chefs you
know that
chefs love curry normally friday night
yeah normally friday but you see that's
the cliche it's like yeah we'll
you know we'll come out of the pub we'll
have a ruby murray we'll eat something
really hot that'll impress our mates and
we'll throw it up on the pavement
outside afterwards
and that's quite an insult to what is a
fabulous i know i know it is insane
which i have to say was one of the
funniest sketches i've ever seen
what are you doing can i come and see
yeah of course you can so
vegetables are in butternut squash
courgettes and aubergine
yeah yeah then i put my almond paste in
with a ginger shallots and garlic almond
paste that's together
i'm going to add my lentils now which
ones are those then these are the pre
lentils
very nice yeah after that coming up the
wind factor right i know
this dish yeah warn you why so yeah no
are you working on new series like
kumar's no well we've done
seven yep and i suppose there is
something about going out on a high
yeah you don't want to hang around
people think i'm good not them again so
what's great there yeah it was fun that
sort of voice you put on
how long does it take you to sort of you
know get up to speed with that
well it's quite instantaneous actually
sexy grandma
so what you'll do to yours next oh is
that it oh i don't know
how many asian mothers does it take to
change a light bulb
i don't know don't worry about me i'll
sit in the dark
hey no all right that's lovely
uh that looks all right and you see it
doubles as a face mask because you can
just put your face
and steve steam your paws and steam away
yeah
so just finish mine with a little touch
more of coconut milk a couple of
tablespoons
freshly chopped coriander and then
squeeze
a fresh lemon in there tell them what
you do now you're putting your
garlic in there yeah it's very simple
it's just garlic tomatoes yeah and
what'd you call that though
a tadka i think it means like a sauce or
a topping maybe
right they both simmer now for 20
minutes then our blind tasters get their
hands on it
and then i'm gonna win simple as that
next on the menu i take my sheep to
palatial pastures
we're going to beckingham palace look at
the size of it
they find it very delicious and i'll
find out who wins the recipe challenge
but the winner for this time yes is
for the past five weeks i've been
looking for the next great female tv
cook
to fill the aprons of delia nigella and
fanny craddock
i've had thousands of applications so
far hi
i'm ellie welcome to my kitchen so let's
see if we can bring back the fanny
but what i want to do today is to make
sure that we use everything that we've
got in the lava so
see you in a bit i've got some stirring
to do now this will be perfect for some
people
other people prefer a richer chocolate
flavor there we go
while that's cooking i'm going to get on
with the mayonnaise
start off by making chocolate magic
melting moments
and i'm hoping that you'll give me a
chance on your program
an asian funny what do you reckon those
are some of my favorites
welcome back to the f word now time for
the results of the recipe challenge and
i'd like to say a big apology to all
mirrors aunties because she's about to
lose
ready thank you ready we're done let's
plate up manage
good okay curry leaves out right
dinner that looks lovely by the way
thank you
want a little taste of course that's
nice
[ __ ] there's a spoon would like to taste
mine
yeah right are you running my dunny okay
where is he my little french fighter
pilot right good luck yep come back with
some good news yes
hey hi how are you okay so dish number
one
and this is your dishwasher
you can really taste the lentils and
that's delicious contains a coriander as
well
it's really nice it brings out the
flavors nice subtle creamy
tastes very kind of fragrant should we
try it on the bread
oh yeah it's a really nice consistency
as well
yeah should go on the second dish okay
let's try this one
this one looks quite green
a lot of flavors in this one very
different good mixture stronger isn't it
it's very close but the winner for this
time
yes is come on stop [ __ ] around who's
the winner
[Applause]
yes no can i just say that was delicious
oh thank you
thank you and you've been an absolute
star and that's one of the most exciting
challenges i've ever had
mila check please thank you my darling
well done
now [ __ ] off at the kitchen take my kid
with me of course you can
several weeks ago i brought my crossbred
lambs charlotte and gavin to london
soon my flock had eaten me out of house
and home scoffing over two kilos of
grass
and veg every day it's damn hard work
like
having a second family of vegetarians
my special sheep have been staying in
sarabini's garden for a couple of weeks
she's done a great job personally
ensuring that they're happy and healthy
where are they in just a few weeks time
they'll be the centerpiece of the f-word
menu
at clara good to see my daddy they have
grown haven't they
they have yeah really they eat a lot
they do don't the grass has gone down
hasn't it
yeah and we've been giving them a lot of
little extra tip bits really they're
very friendly actually they get on very
well with us
and they play football they love it
[Laughter]
sheep will gorge themselves on good
grass and even sarah's lush lawn has not
been enough
[Music]
following shaggy sheep farmer huberly
wittenstahl's advice it's time to move
them up the property ladder
to a new home none of you know where
they're going yet
grandmas grandmas no i don't know
them we'll be there in about one minute
is it david and victoria's house who
said that
well done tilly that's right david and
victoria's i
said that we're going to beckon palace
how lucky are they
thank you mate i've got the zoo with me
and the sheep
thank you how cool is that
david and victoria were in madrid and
couldn't greet their new guests
personally
grass and grass and grass
we were shown round to the back garden
all 17 acres of it
hi guys the grass is so long i've got
your steak
good to see it feel the garden and it's
all
safe and it's all fenced off and
victoria made it very clear if you want
it all checked out and make sure it's
all like this
yeah it's a big moment time to see if my
sheep will take to the new home look at
the size of it
huh thankfully my flock settles quickly
into the lush grass of beckham palace
it's better than being in wales that
will shut up
hugh early wiggins still whinging about
levine in the city
yeah i'm gonna call victoria say thank
you hello
first of all thank you i mean this place
i thought we're gonna put them in a pen
but
we've got the whole back garden thank
you
we wanted to treat your sheep
along the grasses here uh honestly i've
lost my fear we can barely see jack
we've lost small children in that grass
your sheep are gonna be sitting all over
my garden uh but you know can i just say
there's an advantage having sheep [ __ ]
in your back garden you know actually
fertilizes the ground
[Laughter]
i'm gonna miss my sheep they've become
part of the family
and now they're so much further away
from home it's gonna be hard not to
worry about them
21 out 50. desserts
27 out of 50 have agreed to pray let's
be honest
that is a [ __ ] embarrassment
there's one bit of good news you're
definitely definitely definitely not
coming back to the [ __ ] class
now do me a favor yes [ __ ] off out my
kitchen yes
go yes out [ __ ] you now 62
out of 150 that is shocking
the worst by miles